[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
big news out of the comedy world
yesterday as crystalia will be joining
the king and the sting as the third
co-host alongside friends theo van and
brendan schaub uh they're rebranding the
podcast to the king the sting and the
wing the wing being crystalia that's
kind of playing off of his old popular
joke that was like he looks like a tired
bald eagle which is extremely true and
he has that eagle tattoo like on his
wrist and he's just you know they needed
the word wing rhymes with sting and it
also rhymes with king so like total
no-brainer there um
you know they they came out on instagram
kind of blasted the news yesterday they
all posted the same thing and i don't
know why but it just made me laugh the
way that they did it it was like a
picture of all three of them like posing
like you know
flexed up and then it was like you
scroll through there's like five posts
on instagram then there was one of each
of them individually with like their
little logo next to them like a
lightning bolt and a crown and then the
new wing thing that looks just like the
buffalo wild wings logo wing
black and yellow and then it was like
another picture of all three of them
with
i hate when that thing goes out but i'm
just gonna continue talking and then i'm
gonna put that back on and then i'm
gonna act i even wrote a note check
background to make sure that's on but
i'm in the middle of something so i
can't just whatever and then there was a
picture of all three of them with little
jumps let's go
playing you know let's go that song
and it's just like zooming in and out
it's just like this intense it made me
it really reminded me the way that they
set this all up and they're all three
standing there just like with their arms
crossed it looked like an nba team that
just got a new big three and they're
like promoting that on their instagram
instead of three comedians they're just
gonna talk to each other more often and
post it on patreon like it literally
looked like when lebron went to miami
and they were promising not one ring not
two rings but instead of championships
it's just like content on youtube but i
don't know that just made me made me
laugh a little bit
i'm gonna fix that background so it's
probably gonna cut out after this clip
not two not three not four
not five
not six
not seven
but yeah the show seems like it's gonna
be awesome king sting and wing four
times a month every other week going
from youtube and patreon um they even
teased a tour which would be awesome i
guess theo keeps talking about touring
australia but they tease the tour of the
murder tour um because they would just
murder and you know stack up their money
in a pyramid like like they've often
mentioned and a lot of you speaking of
the money thing are like i'm not paying
for stuff on patreon when it's always
been free i found these guys when it was
free you know yeah yeah there's so much
other
free content out there and i totally get
that um paying for
for a podcast on a patreon can seem a
little backwards because podcasts they
always were free but i don't know if
it's really like
a patreon thing where they're trying to
make money i mean obviously everything's
about money but they they also have
mentioned every time they talk about the
patreon episodes that they're tired of
advertisers and that they're tired of
dealing with these you know ad reads or
like they like oh this is brought to you
by draftkings whatever it seems like
reading between the lines how they're
talking about it and the tone of what
you're talking about i'd recommend going
back and watching the last three king
and the singing episodes with chris that
they're doing the patreon thing to get
away from advertisers and to get back to
like
more edgy or off the cover raw
unfiltered commie and i am all about
that so um i'm gonna check out the
patreon personally for at least a month
or two
see if there is a difference in in
content it's not like that they're that
filtered on youtube even i mean the show
is legitimately very very funny um but i
think that it sounds like the patreon
might be the place to be not in like a
greedy way but almost in like a
raw unfiltered comedy way which everyone
who's following this channel i i know
likes because you know the
the the jokes that we like what we think
is funny i can already tell you know we
have a similar sense of humor people
that subscribe to this
channel that commentates on comedy and
people
the comedians that we all follow
together so
yeah very excited about the king and the
sting in the wing i think it's going to
be
a hit like i said i'm probably going to
start off uh doing the patreon thing i
threw this up in my i didn't i didn't
throw up in my community section but i
threw up
the picture of them and
i threw up a picture of them in my
community section said new pod alert
first thoughts on the king the sting and
the wing
uh so let's just go through some of your
comments kind of get a heartbeat on what
the fans are are saying about this and
what you guys are expecting out of this
new show will be a decent pod just a
shitty name don't just add wing fully
rebrand i'd say
i just agree with that i think it was
good to think of something that rhymes
with king and sting although it's
probably aang is like the easiest thing
in the english language to rhyme with
maybe i'm giving them a little too much
credit for thinking of wing and then
tying it back to chris in like two very
basic ways but until i read this like i
really like the name wing but maybe i'm
i'm being too easy on him i can't deal
with chris all the time i'm already
dealing with brendan this guy just comes
on trying to change everything like i
like him as a guest but not as part of
the whole podcast maybe it's just me
he's just too much sometimes
um
yeah i mean they have a lot of guests
and and i don't know if chris is like
trying to change it i mean obviously
they were friends before some of this
stuff happened and um
they're very committed to to chris if
they're going to make a whole king sting
and wing rebrand and
uh on patreon stuff so they seem
committed i don't think he's being too
pushy even when you watch the episodes
like
i you know i think chris is hilarious he
gets on that stick of of his and then
theo will like mock him in the funniest
ways and chris just does not know what
to do about it dude and he's just
sitting there and he's like dude i hate
that you can do me so well and i can't
do you and like watching chris and theo
interact is just so it's my favorite
part it's so funny dude like they are so
funny so
i don't know i think that they're all
gonna get along really well and that
he's gonna blend together um but i can
see why you would say that if you were
already a big king and sting fan why you
might think oh this wing is trying to
come in here and
um
i don't know i think it's really funny
looks like a group of lifeguards from
hot topic
um
i
does hot topic have like a are people
drowning in hot topics is is that even
pop like why would
i'm gonna lose my mind i don't know how
to get that to stay on but to finish my
joke why would there be lifeguards at
hot topic there's no body of water there
there's no life
[ __ ]
hot topic lifeguards don't exist i'm
going to fix the screen again
i think i'm going to keep that in i mean
i can't wait until they take over and
just turns into insulting brendan
there are a lot of comments like this
um
and just my background in comedy besides
like stan performing stand up is being a
big fan of theo and chris specifically
and i've never really got
too much into brendan or even into the
king and the sting in general like i
said i binged kind of all these chris
episodes before making this video and
when i heard this announcement because
i'm such too i'm a big fan of those two
guys so much but brendan i just never
really got into i watched some of his
jre episodes so i don't know much about
him
it seems like there's some sort of
undeniable vein on the internet that is
against him
i don't know why that is um
so i'm just going to try not to get into
that but a lot of these comments seem
very
anti-brendan
i don't know why that is someone should
explain that to me if you want to
comment you know some reasons why
i'm getting this vibe that would be
helpful thank you
but no offense to brendan i don't know
either three of these people i'm just
reading the comments
two legendary comedians and a bloated
italian drowning victim
so i'm starting off
very strong on the
um i'm assuming that's brennan but 46
other people i think uh that like that
assumed the same thing
could be called the king the sting and
the fling changing guests faster than
theo changed girlfriends and that has
been a thing i know stevie's been on
there eric griffin a lot of people have
been
they're flying through these guests and
these co-hosts and stuff but obviously
this sounds like it's more official and
more cemented because they're you know
made this big announcement they they
made their uh nba big three announcement
and they're going on patreon so
definitely should will they still be
playing musical chairs that's something
that theo was talking about in all the
episodes too like i don't know where we
should sit i don't know where we should
sit and they were kind of goofing on him
on that these are really funny there's
three i think episodes up right now of
of the king sting in the wing without it
being called that of just these three
brendan theowen and chris up right now
and there were some times i was watching
in here alone laughing out loud like
this is a
good top-tier comedy podcast right now
and i'm just
assuming that patreon is going to take
that to the next level
but we'll see and i'll let you know
obviously not going to show stuff from
the patreon but i'll let you know what i
think about it because i'm going to like
i said sign up for that and i recommend
that you do too um the king and the wing
would have been a million times better
like i said there's a lot of comments
like this but i'm not gonna lie that
there are comments defending him in my
community section so go check that out
joke world community section we post
polls and and cool pictures and just
stuff related comedy every day that you
guys can comment on and throw in your
two cents because obviously it's fun to
throw in your two cents that's what i'm
doing right now
um theo and two civilian guests nice
thea's coattails are carrying some
weight uh damn theo carrying both these
dudes now pay for his chiropractor a lot
of
just theo comments you know so there's a
mix of everything um
and just how the internet is there tends
to be more negative stuff and comments
than
you know positive stuff like this post
got what like 150 likes and there were
100 comments it seems like
half these comments are just people
looking looking to vent some things but
people are excited about this people are
are very excited about this in the
comments who gold you know so excited
crystalia provides a bump this guy
said why does theo keep these bozos
relevant we only want to watch him
then this guy says theo sucks lately so
that's what i mean about the internet
one guy can love you and one guy can
hate you so i guess this really is not
indicative of anything
uh the same people just keep making the
same different podcasts with different
names it's really
oversaturated at this point
that's true
but
we're gonna do more power to them i mean
that's what we wanted to take the power
away from these corporations like comedy
central and put them into the comedian's
hands to do whatever they want so
can't really complain about them doing
whatever they want you know i'm excited
about this i think this is great i think
there should be more collabs it'd be
cool to get like an la and new york
comic like crossover collab well and
that just made me think of the traveling
thing and like
there's already a joke on king in this
thing that theo is not showing up or
like he's you know because he's natural
to la yada ya like all that stuff and he
there's already like steel even going to
show up like even in their outro thing
where he's running out of gas like
four times a month is a lot so i hope
that they're not just
filming all four episodes in a two-week
span
because that seems like a money grab you
know but i don't know how he's going to
travel that much or if he's going to
miss episodes because then if you're
paying for that and theo's missing
episodes and a lot of people just want
to see more theo
that's going to be a whole thing so i'm
curious to see how they maneuver that um
because you know how like when two bears
one cave when tom moved austin and then
there was a time where bert was coming
in and it seemed like there was jamming
in episodes like it was so business-like
and it wasn't like
two guys two friends two best friends
hanging out um so i hope it still feels
like three three really funny friends
hanging out for the king the staying in
the wing and not just like let's film
four episodes as fast as we can get paid
and get back to nashville most people
hating on the sting thought he was funny
until they see a comment that said
otherwise and i think that's a big part
of the internet is you know you make
your own opinion in your head then you
might see other comments and get nervous
oh no one agrees with that okay now i'm
gonna start just taking on the popular
stance so yeah
like
like i said i don't know why people seem
to be against brendan it seems like
people thought he was funny until they
read other comments saying that he's not
and and then they just want to get in on
the popular opinion i don't know that's
a good point chris saving the pod all
three are hilarious love it like there's
very there's very positive comments too
not paying for [ __ ] when there's more
free content on a million channels i
i'll use this time while the patrons
make them 3k a piece and find some new
comments on the horizon everyone acts
like their content should be locked
behind a closed door blah blah 99 of us
found them for free
just makes so much sense but like i was
saying i think the patreon might just be
to let it fly a little bit more and not
have to worry about the annoying you
know little trolls on twitter so yeah
shorter video today just wanted to come
on and you know touch base about this
new news in the comedy world king sting
and wing three very major comedians
teaming up for another uh joint podcast
which has gone so well in the past two
bears one cage
two bears one cage that would be
a good wrestling match or a good uh
promotion for them two bears one cage
and then it's a
either two bears in cage or tom and bert
wrestling um two bears one cave went
really well bad friends is like so funny
like those are two of the funniest
things out there so i mean
tuesdays with stories another you know
combo there's so many combos and and now
we get our first threesome our first
menage a trois podcast there's probably
other ones but i just said the first one
so don't correct me on that and i'm very
excited i'm gonna be listening gonna be
tuning in i'm gonna let you guys know
how it is
i recommend doing it yourself too go
check out their other episodes you know
announcing this on their instagrams and
stuff and um
speaking of instagram
please go follow joke world on instagram
we're featuring a new stamp comedian
every day a new smaller guy who we're
trying to put spotlight on give him a
chance and then we're also featuring you
know other content like on our youtube
channel there so if you're watching this
video right now i guarantee that you
would like our instagram i just
guarantee it and there's you know 50 000
more of you here than there and if we
could get you over there it would give
these people that were spotlighting a
real audience and a real like chance to
be recognized by people it'd be awesome
it would be something positive for the
comedy world and it would give people a
chance a platform that we control you
know me and you people like us who have
the same sense of humor get to control
it it's not going to get you know
filtered and and and
censored and and
it's everything that we just said that
the patreon could potentially be for the
king and the sting that's joke world's
instagram right now and if we could get
you guys all over there it would just
make it so much better it'd mean the
world to those comedians and you know to
me too so get over there and the best
part is we're giving everyone a free
joke world sticker that follows and dm's
it's just gm us your address it's it's
real
for free no strings attached you will
get some of these in the mail um we're
reposting everyone who sends them where
they posted them at so we'll even
feature you on our page if you're not a
comedian just get these stickers post
them somewhere and you're up there
guaranteed so thanks for watching come
back next time and go check out the king
the sting and the wing
[Music]
you